(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Complementando a informação sobre o leilão judicial de direitos do prometente
comprador, quando o contrato ali que o prometente comprador fez com o vendedor
está quitado.
A gente falou lá em um momento anterior aqui dessa aula, que se o imóvel tiver
quitado, o arrematante vai ter que pagar dois ETIs e dois registros para
regularizar a compra anterior, já que a matrícula segue uma continuidade.
Então, a carta de arrematação não tem como passar o imóvel do devedor para o
arrematante, se o devedor não constar na matrícula do imóvel.
Então, para registrar essa carta de arrematação, passando o imóvel do devedor
para o arrematante, o arrematante antes vai ter que registrar a compra anterior
que não foi registrada, que é a compra que o devedor fez com o terceiro.
Para pagar dois ETIs e dois registros, o arrematante precisaria ter em mãos a
escritura que esse devedor, que na verdade é o comprador do imóvel, fez lá com
o vendedor que constava na matrícula, porque se não tiver escritura, o cartório
não vai aceitar registrar primeiro o imóvel no nome do devedor.
Só que a escritura nem sempre existe.
Se existir escritura, tudo bem, você pega a escritura, leva ao cartório de
imóveis responsável por aquele imóvel, paga o ETI, paga o registro, registra o
imóvel no nome do devedor e depois registra sua carta de arrematação com
pagamento de novo ETI e de novo registra.
Se não existir escritura, vai ser necessário o arrematante entrar com uma ação
de adjudicação compulsória para que o juiz que recebe essa ação de adjudicação
compulsória determine que o cartório de imóveis registre o imóvel em nome do
arrematante, independente de existir ali a escritura e o pagamento de ETI e
registro para regularizar a compra anterior que aquele devedor fez.
Se existir essa ação de adjudicação compulsória, o arrematante vai precisar
comprovar naquela ação que ele arrematou um leilão de direitos, que dentro
daquele processo que levou o imóvel a leilão, tem a informação de que a compra
que o devedor fez anteriormente com outro proprietário está quitada, que não
tem uma escritura, então que ele não conseguiria primeiro registrar o imóvel no
nome do devedor, que ele já quer passar direto logo para o registro da carta de
arrematação em seu nome.
Nessa ação de adjudicação compulsória, o juiz pode determinar que o cartório de
registro de imóveis registre diretamente o imóvel no nome do arrematante, sem
precisar da escritura, sem precisar do ETI, sem precisar do registro.
Mas por que eu continuo achando o leilão de direitos uma coisa que não é tão
vantajosa?
Porque essa ação de adjudicação compulsória te custa um dinheiro, você vai
precisar de um advogado para entrar nessa ação, você vai precisar pagar os
custos processuais dessa ação, você vai precisar esperar a decisão desse juiz,
então é um procedimento muito mais complexo do que você arrematar o imóvel que
foi levado a leilão, a propriedade do imóvel e não os direitos do imóvel.
Então sempre fique bem atento a isso em leilão de direitos, você precisa saber
que vai ter essa consequência.
Se por acaso tem informação no processo judicial que está levando o imóvel em
leilão, de que aquele contrato que o devedor fez para compra e venda está
quitado e tem escritura de compra e venda, você pode pegar essa escritura,
levar ao cartório, pagar a ITBI, pagar o registro, transferir a propriedade
para o devedor e depois registrar sua carta de arrematação.
Se por acaso existir a informação nesse processo judicial que está levando o
imóvel em leilão, de que a compra que o devedor fez está quitada, mas não tem
escritura pública de compra e venda, você vai precisar entrar com uma ação de
adjudicação compulsória para que o juiz determine o cartório de imóveis que
registra diretamente o imóvel no nome do arrematante, mas lembre que isso aí
você vai precisar pagar honorários de um advogado e custos processuais e
esperar essa decisão do juiz.
Então é sempre mais vantajoso que você participe dos leilões de propriedade e
não dos leilões judiciais de direitos.
E se por acaso existir no processo judicial que está levando o imóvel em leilão
informação de que a compra que o devedor fez não está integralmente quitada,
vale aquilo que a gente falou em um momento anterior aqui da aula.
O arrematante também vai ficar no lugar do devedor assumindo o saldo ali que o
devedor tem em aberto com o vendedor daquele imóvel, com quem vendeu o imóvel
para aquele devedor.
Então fique bem atento a isso.
Pagar dois registros e dois ITBIs ou recorrer a uma ação de adjudicação
compulsória somente se constar no processo que está levando ao imóvel em leilão
de que aquele contrato de compra e venda que o devedor fez está quitado.
Se não tiver quitado, fique atento que pode sobrar ainda uma dívida da
aquisição do imóvel para você pagar assim como acontece no leilão judicial de
direitos do devedor fiduciante.
Muito cuidado com leilão de direitos.
Nunca pense que você está comprando a propriedade em um leilão judicial de
direitos.
Fique sempre bem atento a isso.